Busuu is one of the world's leading applications for language learning
Our goal is to empower everyone in the world
From learning a new language
We achieve it through
Provide high quality educational courses for users
Designed in-house and equipped with conversations
With speakers in the original language
So you learn a language
It should be done with people who speak it
This is what users like about our app
It is social interaction
To date, more than 65 million people have used it
Application Busuu to learn language
And four of the top five markets
Markets for Android are for countries with emerging markets
Turkey, Russia, Brazil and India
We realized that many emerging markets
It has limited storage and memory capabilities and has a slow connection
Internet or intermittent, so we started to offer more to support
Users in those countries
Network log is the first tool
We used it
And we were able to reduce
The amount of data being exchanged
Because we were able to process some errors in the app icon
The other tool we use is the Memory Analyzer,
And by which we were able to ascertain
Memory only includes the necessary content
Without any unnecessary additions
We offer language learning applications
We allow the use of different languages ​​for the interface
The Lint tool is great for us
And by which we were able to ascertain
Our data is complete and 100%
While focusing on performance
We noticed that the database is huge
So we decided to get rid of the database
And rely on Internet connection
We were able to reduce the APK size from 60MB
To 25 MB
This was a great development for us
We received more downloads from emerging markets
And to continue our work on improving performance
Average weekly ratings rose from 4.1 to 4.5
It is the highest rating we have received
It is the duties of every software developer
Ensure compliance
With all kinds of devices and all usage environments
And using more tools to improve performance
The life of the developer will be easier
Performance is a key factor
Can not be ignored or overlooked
You have to make an effort
To instill in the culture of business activity.